[Music]
all right in this week's vegas drive
we're going to take you to boulder city
jillian takes us for an eight mile ride
on the rail explorers
[Music]
we have made our way to boulder city one
of my favorite places right outside of
las vegas and today we're hopping across
the train tracks and we are going to be
rail explorers for the day i can't wait
to go jump on the bikes it's going to be
so much fun let's go check it out
[Music]
you can experience the magic of the
railroad like no place else so we
actually put you on rail bikes it gets
you right in and on those tracks we take
you four miles out into the mojave
desert turn you around and bring it
right back in with unique tours
throughout the year there's a little
something for everyone we have night
lights so we run about 9 30 10 o'clock
into the evening so
star gazing we've got fire pits at the
west end all of our bikes are
retrofitted with led lights so there is
a little bit of a night light tour the
rail explorer's family has strong ties
to the community implementing a
wristband system with special offers in
boulder city you can take that wristband
into the community um and we've got
about eight or nine hoping to bring up
on more businesses and they offer an
exclusive discount to um rail explorer's
customers we've got the history of
boulder city and the museum the building
of hoover dam we've got the great
outdoors and then we've of course got
you know bike riding you're getting me
excited i think it's time we go jump on
one of the bikes what do you think let's
do it without further ado there are name
tags only black book rights on every
single bike it's the name you reserved
under after a safety briefing it's time
to buckle up and you can go ahead and
pedal backwards to give you an idea of
where you need to be
cool and you are ready to go
how fast do these typically go well
we've got uh regulators on it so we
don't let y'all go fast but they do get
up we got um you know the crew goes out
and has a good time have some fun
15 to 20 miles per hour really for the
um
for the customer bikes during the eight
mile round trip you can take in all the
beautiful desert scenery all right we
can kick back and relax now it's all
downhill
and the best part anyone is welcome on
the rail explorer bikes so much fun
isn't that great and i have to tell you
i think you know one of my favorite
aspects about rail explorers is because
the way that these bikes are designed
we have really no limitations i mean
we're fully accessible
to everybody i mean we have no weight
limits we have no age limits we have uh
really no ability limits i mean i've
taken 100 year old women i've taken a
paraplegic halfway through the trip at
about the four mile mark you can rest
your legs and hang out in the picnic
area well we've made it to the halfway
point almost about four miles on the
rail explorers we're about to turn the
bikes around and ride back but heather
thank you so much this is such a fun
adventure and just seeing all the
beautiful scenery and you were awesome
so thanks for having us out here
absolutely it was great to have you all
right you guys be sure to come check out
rail explorer starting in the fall
they'll have tours every day so you
don't want to miss it i'm going to take
a little breather and then we're going
to head back